nike dunk high sb pro 200
1 000
that's a 1500 square foot house off a
half an acre with like updated
appliances
it was good job it's your boy cordee i
got unlimited bread from gq so let's go
on the shopping spree
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so let's look at some sneakers
jordan 8 retro kobe bryant p.e
celebration pack made for kobe's
retirement white and purple oh that's
hard 40 g's though
ah
[Music]
if it ain't my money hell yeah with gq
money for sure i'm gonna buy this [ __ ]
i met kobe twice man colin kaepernick um
actually introduced me to kobe he's like
yeah uh he just dropped his debut album
um it should be again grammy nominated
and colby was like word man congrats and
i was like yeah man i'm gonna take that
thing home he's like yup you do it again
you do it again you do it again you do
it again you just keep on doing it his
mindset and mentality you know just for
our first time meeting and him just
sending forth that light into me and
this is our first time meeting i'm gonna
buy these drums cuz i know they're gonna
go up in value some sneakers can be
investment pieces so i'm definitely get
these especially when it's y'all bread
all right next nike dunk the what the
dunk sb's twenty thousand two hundred
and seventy two dollars you know what's
crazy these are the joints that i will
for my sneaker shopping thing that'd
always be popping up man in retrospect i
should have got this shoe because i'm
thinking about to be like 1500 at the
max i just heard 4 000 and at that point
in my career [ __ ] even now i'm still
going i'm not about to just drop no 4gs
on sneakers like i said some sneakers
can be investments matter of fact you
know i'm gonna credit myself for making
these go up in value i made these go up
without you know
for the sake of memorabilia we're gonna
put that in the cart but damn ain't that
crazy though like these drinks is 20
bands now ah that's crazy all right next
god damn
nike dunk high sb pro
200 000
who made these jokes futura it's not
like he make the prices anyway but god
damn i ain't dropping 200 g's i'll be on
zillow all the time that's a 1500 square
foot house off a half an acre with like
updated appliances i would never wear
them it's an investment piece it's like
you don't wear your apple stock hell no
them james is in a vault moving on new
boundless 992 gray 280s you know i'm a
puma guy
shout out to the good folks at pool well
you know i'm from maryland so new
balance is just is like culture man i
don't know why we've been putting on for
new balance when it wasn't cool i say
that to say like i buy these i buy these
won't wear them though okay so sneaker
summaries
one only one i'm gonna get them kobe's
them eights i'm keeping those forever
y'all got me worried now man we gonna
start off with some 200 000 shoes let's
check out some accessories um i'm into
buying high level
no pun intended accessories like
a designer passport a wildlife louis
vuitton vogees voles voyages paperweight
2070
it's some fly [ __ ] just on some like
just trying to flex
next up gucci crocodile bifold wallet
2500
imma say no cause i'm not a big
crocodile fan i just don't like how i
look i had an uncle who always used to
wear gators and [ __ ] and that [ __ ] just
threw me off i i got a black wallet but
it's like a louis monogram but it ain't
gator okay tom ford octagon diamond
cufflinks 55 000. imagine wearing this
with like a burlington coat factory suit
okay so 18 karat white gold blue
sapphire stone swords from salon
like just in the grand scheme of thing
of like you know what 50 g's can do for
somebody you know that you got on your
cufflinks i just think that's just like
grossly rich if i got 50 000 cuff links
i would have to donate like
10 million dollars if that's like of
what money is to me if that makes sense
if jay-z gave me the cuff links i'mma
keep them jones tom ford buckley
alligator duffel 41 000
you know what's funny i met tom ford at
the met gala and he was a cool ass dude
a lot of alligators so but you know what
just off the strength of tom ford being
a cool guy this duffel bag being worth
42 thousand dollars i'm gonna get it for
now i'm gonna get i'm gonna hold on to
it because you know what i do in real
life if it's like an item that i really
that i'm putting the store so i don't
like pressure myself to buy it i'll go
home and if i'm still thinking about the
next day i'm gonna just grab them
because you can't put a price on peace
of mind happiness you know but when it's
somebody else's money
swipe that's why especially gq money all
right so i'm gonna get the louis vuitton
paperweight
i'm uh and i'm gonna get the time for
buckley alligator duffel add it to the
car
you know what's funny i like spending
money on things even if it's like
expensive because it makes life a little
more convenient and easier for me let's
check out some tech real quick wilson
master
chronosonic speakers 928 thousand
dollars 100 i don't even got to say 130.
that's a smooth m
you know when i first got
money the first thing i did was invest
into a good studio to put in my house
i'm spending a lot of my like
hard-earned money to make sure i'm
giving the best
show whether i'm bringing a live band
i'm
investing in my production wilson master
chronosonic speakers
cool and
a little slight m you know what's the m
m a little cool off the humble tip okay
orion x2 dual system extreme overclock
pc forty thousand pinnacle complete pc
systems complete with ultra high and
equipment intel core
i don't play game listen man i'm an
investor on some studio equipment i know
i'm gonna get that back times 10. [ __ ]
even them kobe's from earlier that's a
sentimental investment too you know it's
more than just a monetary investment it
can be an investment into your happiness
this computer has no investment for me
because i don't even play games moving
on okay board eight yacht club nft 260
000. i've been seeing this [ __ ] so it's
like you're buying yourself into this
expensive neighborhood in the metaverse
anything that can possibly make me even
more money even if it tanks like i'm
gonna get it it can't hurt i'm gonna get
this jump it's straight it's not my cup
of tea but art is subjective you know
samsung 99-inch home theater display 130
000. 4k
ultra hd i would buy this
i would definitely buy this there's some
fly [ __ ] to have in the living room a
movie theater you imagine being on
shrooms and just watching tv
technology summary
so the million dollar speakers the
wilson master chronosonic speakers i'm
gonna get them jones i'm gonna get the
board eight yacht club nft and i'm gonna
get that samsung 99 inch
home theater display
places to live two park place pinnacle
penthouse 80 million dollars built in
1910
730 feet high right home with 10 mil 10
000 square feet of interior space door
man yeah this [ __ ] is fly indoor pool i
love being out in new york man this is
the vibe like [ __ ] i don't give a if
it's my type of crib or not i'm gonna
buy this show next up san marcos island
miami beach house 20 million dollars you
know what i have a pool and i don't
really swim in it pretty that often
unless like families in town so i can do
without it but i left my heater on for
like a week because my family was in
town you know you cut on the pool here i
left the heat and i went out of town i
left the heater on for like two weeks
and didn't even realize it until i came
back my electric bill was so [ __ ]
high bro sunset boulevard estate la
hills 85 million 30 000 square feet 17
bedrooms
damn
ah
oh it's not it's kind of big honestly
that's a big ass chandelier huh you just
say my vibe then if i can only choose
moving on the central land corner pocket
on the d paws
seven million dollars ethereum unique
location rolled on three sides expires
in 201 years
i know what ethereum is but
decentralized corner pocket on the d
it's like metaverse [ __ ] right this may
be the best investment piece but real
estate in real life never goes wrong
either so i'm gonna go with the real
life real estate oh so it's seven
million aetherium uh ethereum is
probably like forty one hundred dollars
right now
so four thousand times seven million is
damn a lot
[Laughter]
it's a lot i'm gonna get that new york
crib that's the most like my vibe my
style i like the staircases i like the
interior decor yeah i'm gonna get the
new york drink
[Music]
that's it shout out to gq for taking me
on the shopping spree with uh all of
y'all bread y'all like a damn sugar
daddy huh